hey what's up my beautiful weebs diavalo
here and today we are going to look at
the guy who started it all
yuta akatsu but before we get into all
that remember to hear about that like
button and leave a comment down below
with who you'd like to see in the next
character analysis
if you're new around here be sure to
also subscribe if you're into anime and
especially jujutsu kaizen content
anyway so yuda ikotsu is the main
protagonist of jujutsu kaizen's prequel
series jiu jitsu kaizen zero jiu-jitsu
high he was initially a special grade
cursed human haunted by his late
childhood friend rika aramito
yuta is a young man of average size with
a messy head of black hair and dark blue
eyes his body language makes it easy to
tell that yuda is very stressed and his
posture is very unconfident
and he has dark eyelids due to his lack
of sleep
at his old school yuta wore a suit for
the uniform he sports a long sleeve
shirt that stops at his forearms or a
black t-shirt and dark green pants for
casual wear
after transferring to tokyo jujutsu high
yudho received a specialized uniform
user has a loose white jacket with
sleeves that stop
at his forearms the rest of his uniform
appears to be the usual jiu-jitsu high
dark colours
he also often carries his sword on his
back
yudu was a very timid and lonely boy who
was bullied a lot while growing up due
to rika haunting much of his early life
yutu was unable to connect with other
people and has lost all confidence in
himself this makes it difficult for you
to interact with others
as they often scare him without meaning
to or is just too shy to speak to them
even so yuta genuinely cared about other
people and decided to isolate himself
from them even if it means remaining
alone
maki zenning called out yusuf for being
a moody kid who's lived his entire life
without
goals he even acknowledged this was true
and used her advice to gain a meaning
for being a jiu-jitsu sorcerer this
helps user realize that deep down he
truly desires the confidence to feel
like he belongs
yuta still struggled to understand
someone like toge and yumaki he was
initially scared of toge
until he realized how kind of a person
he truly is and made an effort to
establish a social connection between
the two of them even though
he was initially wary of togo gaining
friends helps you to gain confidence in
himself and establish the goal to help
set rika free he felt responsible for
turning her into a curse in the first
place and worked extremely hard to find
a way to help her
at his core yuta wants to become someone
who can help keep
others out of danger duties abilities
and power
yuda akotsu is one of only four special
grade sorcerers recognized by jujutsu
high
while being haunted by rika's cursed
spirit yuta was immediately registered
as a special grade due to reeka's
immense power he apparently dominated
all of the other kyoto students in the
2017 goodwill event and was able to
defeat suguru ghetto after releasing the
limiter on rika's powers
after training with gojo and the other
students he used to learn to control his
cursed energy and becomes reliable with
a sword
even after rika's curse is dispelled
yuta still retains his special grade
ranking and gojo has stated that yuta
has the potential to even surpass him
yuta's great power comes from being a
descendant of one of the big three
vengeful spirits of japan it is the
reason he cursed rika when he rejected
her death at a young
age yuta trained for the majority of
overseas with miguel a talented sorcerer
commended by gojo since his return
yuta has become a masterful jujutsu
sorcerer entrusted by the jujutsu
higher-ups to handle curses and execute
sakuna's vessel
upon confronting yuji naoya xenin and
cho so both
exceptional jujutsu users recognised
that yuta was far
more powerful than both of them naoya
especially who prides himself on his
abilities
quickly allied himself to uta to avoid
any potential conflict
chosu advised yuji to run at all costs
because fighting user would ensure death
comparing his strength to saturday gojo
yuta is an expert swordsman yuda was
given a katana to channel reeka's power
though vigorous training with maki a
cursed tool user yukta became decent
with a sword
able to hold his own against powerful
cursed spirits and even suguru ghetto
who has exceptional physical prowess
as a second year student yuda continues
to wield his katana as his main weapon
he is far more proficient and moves
extremely well as a swordsman yuta
reinforces his body and blade with
cursed energy allowing him to wield it
with superhuman
physical prowess he defeated a large
high-level grade cursed spirit with a
diving stab
so powerful it cracked the ground below
it yuta's power comes from his relation
to
zugawata but it only first manifested
when he transformed rika into a cursed
spirit
rika became a vengeful spirit so
powerful that suguru ghetto
an avid collector of powerful spirits
dubbed her the queen of curses
rika's boundless cursed energy could be
shaped into any technique allowing users
use advanced jujutsu shortly after
learning how to use it
cursed energy manipulation despite
rika's spirit getting unraveled from the
curse yuta retains the immense amount of
curse energy well after the event he
admitted the amount of his cursed power
was even greater than gojo's however
yuta's energy will be exhausted much
faster than his teacher who could
flawlessly manage the energy expenditure
thanks to his six eyes yuji and choso
could immediately tell from yuta's
presence that his curse energy was on
par with gojo
with the former claiming that it was
even more creepy and ominous
initially as someone who has only been
studying jiu-jitsu for a year as of 2018
yuta was still learning the ropes on how
to control his curse energy he quickly
learned how to channel some of it into
his ring or his katana but would often
rely on reika's full power rather than
finally controlling it on his own while
fighting sugar ghetto yuta imbued
excessive cursed energy into his kantana
and at once
shattered it as a result following his
year overseas yutu returned to japan
with much greater control over his
massive amounts of cursed energy he made
up for his lack of physical strength by
strengthening his entire body and weapon
with constant flows of her synergy while
in battle the state increased the
strength and speed tremendously and made
the opponents unable to read his energy
flows
yuta's every attack carries incredible
destructive power
and he can restrict all incoming damage
to himself to a minimum
by falling to the ground with his body
reinforced yuta shattered the ground
from the impact additionally his
reinforced physical skills are improved
to such a degree that he can contend
with yuji iridori's natural physical
prowess he can match
yuji's blistering speed while carrying a
drone katana he even threw
a car back at yuji after the sorcerer
with superhuman strength tossed it at
him first
uter and his swords yuta was provided a
katana by gojo
as a vessel to channel reeka's curse
energy at first he struggled to properly
focus the cursed energy on the blade and
only managed shallow cuts against strong
cursed spirits
after vigorous training and experience
on missions yuta learns properly to
wield the sword with reeker's power
however
it was a standard katana and could not
take an overflow of the cursed energy
breaking as a result
yuta received another katana after
breaking the first one and continues to
use it even without the original
reeker's presence he is a much more
proficient swordsman with his new katana
which he carries everywhere in a black
case
in battle yuta leaves the sheath on his
waistband and fights with a sword drawn
at all times his main form of combat
appears to be
swordplay reinforced by vast cursed
energy
cursed ability rika after returning to
japan from his overseas trip u2 was able
to manifest rika once again
he has an even greater degree of control
over this manifestation than he did
earlier in his life even being capable
of forming the spirit partially
it is currently unknown if this entity
is related to rika orimoto or a
different manifestation altogether
reverse curse technique thanks to rika's
immense levels of cursed energy yuta was
quickly able to adapt to his friend's
injuries and use a reversed curse
technique to heal all of them at once
youtube used the advanced healing
ability with less than a year's worth of
jujutsu training with rika's power
cursed rika manifestation a special
grade vengeful spirit rika has only been
manifested twice
both times showcased that she is truly
one of the most powerful cursed spirits
to ever exist
while haunting yuta she could attack
anyone who got too close to him using
her arms without fully manifesting
herself and he could draw cursed energy
from her
fully manifesting with only a small
percentage of her power rika can
effortlessly kill
giant curses at full force rika was able
to contend with nearly every cursed
spirit in ghetto's arsenal after
surpassing her limits rika's power was
far beyond every curse and ghetto's
collection that put together into his
maximum uzumaki technique copied curse
techniques
using an outside source for snake eyes
and fangs
yusu can replicate toge's cursed speech
something
usually reserved for the sentence of the
anumaki clan yuta has difficulty
controlling the cursed energy released
by the technique but it's highly
effective nonetheless
he was able to command every single one
of ghetto's swarm of lower grade curses
to die
at once which is just crazy so
anyway
for now this is all i could find about
yuta akotsu and his abilities so far in
the jiu jitsu kaizen universe
though i think in the coming weeks in
the manga we will possibly see even more
abilities that he could possibly have as
he has finally made an appearance and is
on the same side as
the man yuji anyway if you guys have
enjoyed the video
be sure to headbutt the absolute
out of that like button as it helps out
with the algorithm
and leave a comment down below with what
you guys think also be sure to subscribe
if you're under similar content to do
with anime and gaming but for now it's
been your professional degenerate
diavolo and i'll see you guys in a bit
bye
[Music]
you